okay so uh yeah thanks for inviting me
uh this is
uh sketching is a tool for numerical
linear algebra
i'll cover uh
uh several recent results uh in this
direction so i'll first discuss
regression
mention
exact regression algorithms
and then show how sketching can be used
to speed up these algorithms i'll show
it for
least squares regression
then least absolute deviation regression
then i'll look at low rank approximation
show how sketching is uh useful in that
context
and then i'll discuss some more uh
recent results um using sketching for uh
an m estimation problem for
regression um and also curr
decompositions
so
let me just get started with regression
and give you the basic idea how
sketching is uh is useful for obtaining
faster algorithms
so in linear regression um
so we're going to only focus on linear
regression in this talk and it's just a
statistical method to study linear
dependencies between variables in the
presence of noise right so
here's uh some example uh where we have
uh
ohm's law being the voltage is equal to
the resistance times the current
we have a bunch of voltage uh current uh
uh pairs
which are points in the plane and we're
trying to find a linear function that
best fits this data under some notion of
a fitness and there are many different
notions and we'll discuss a number of
them in the talk
um
so the standard setting is there's one
measured variable b
in the previous example this was the the
voltage
and we have a set of predictor variables
uh a1 through a d
and the previous example d was equal to
one and we just had the current
being the predictor variable
and the assumption is that
this measure variable and the predictor
variables are linearly related
up to some noise so
what that means is that b
is equal to
x naught plus a one x one plus dot dot
dot a d x d
plus some epsilon
um
where epsilon is assumed to be noise and
the x i are
model parameters that we're trying to
learn so they're the uh the coefficients
of the hyperplane
uh that causes these variables to be
linearly related
by standard transformations you can
assume that the uh this free coefficient
x naught is equal to zero
and um let me just cast uh this problem
uh in uh
so now you're just trying to find a
subspace uh
hyperplane through the origin
let me just cast the problem as uh in
matrix form
uh so we can
uh talk about it in this way
so
you're given an n by d matrix a
uh as well as a vector b
uh
and um n is the number of observations
and d is the number of uh these
predictor variables
and the regression problem is just to uh
find uh a vector x star
so that ax star and b are close
okay that's just the whole problem
um
and uh for this talk we're going to
consider the over constrained case
when n is much larger than d
um so this is a a common case that
arises and um
so there need not be a solution here
right there there may not be an x star
so that ax star
is equal to b
um and uh there is a way here that uh
we're gonna assume that a has full
column rank in this talk uh you can
actually uh
actually using one of lapsi's results
you can
replace a with some with with an a which
has full full column rank very quickly
but i won't get into that here so let's
just assume that
and um
er
what's going on with the slides
so
um
uh so let me discuss a few uh notions of
uh measuring uh
uh closeness uh
uh in regression
so probably the most common uh way of
doing this is the least squares method
right you want to find an x star that
minimizes the euclidean distance between
ax and b
right
and just for notation um
so
a i star is the i throw of a
so this is just uh you know the height
observation bi minus the inner product
of a i star and x
um
uh yeah so this is this has certain
desirable statistical properties so um
it's uh
known to be a maximum likelihood
estimator if your uh
if your noise is gaussian
and uh it actually has a closed form
solution
as well so you know the the solution to
the least squares uh regression problem
is given by um
uh you know x equals uh a transpose a
inverse a transpose b
right so so there's actually a closed
form solution which comes from solving
uh
the normal equations uh
to this problem the so-called normal
equations
okay so that's
that's one uh
you know form of regression
another form is uh least absolute
deviation
or l1 regression
and here you're just trying to find the
next star which minimizes the one norm
between uh a x and b okay that's
um
and uh
typically the cost is less sensitive to
outliers than least squares uh the
reason people i mean the reason this is
the case is because if one of your
measurements bi is
is you know corrupt is slightly bad then
you're trying a lot harder to fit it
when you're squaring this
this difference in least squares than in
least absolute deviation
um
and for for l1 regression you can also
solve this uh
you know in polynomial time just via
linear programming
okay so um we don't have a closed form
solution but we still have this and uh
you know you can
create n auxiliary variables to deal
with these absolute values you can solve
it in um you know in
poly and d time
okay um
right so these time complexities for
both of these problems are at least n
times d squared and we would like to uh
to solve these problems uh faster
okay are there any questions about this
is just the basic setup for regression
technically that would be like a matrix
multiplication exponent minus one rather
than a square yeah so um
yeah for least squares uh
you can get uh n times d to the omega
minus one uh
if you use fast matrix multiplication
and you're and you're just talking about
dense case you're thinking the matrices
are default yeah uh so this uh
so far i'm just talking about the dance
case yeah
yeah there's another notion called
totally squares but you know which isn't
so widely used but that's another
version of least squares or instead of a
vertical distance it's sort of a
perpendicular distance oh okay yeah
definitely yeah there are so many
notions of regression uh i'm just
covering a handful of them
okay um
right so those are some exact regression
algorithms and now let me uh introduce
the technique of sketching uh as a way
of speeding up least squares regression
so first we're going to relax the
problem to
an approximation problem
we'd like to output
an x prime for which the euclidean
distance between ax prime and b is at
most one plus epsilon times the optimal
cost with high probability
and
the
the way to use uh
sketching is sort of a sketch and solve
paradigm so let me
let me just state the idea here
so the idea is that
you draw a matrix s
um from a
from a random family of matrices
and i'll go over uh different families
now s is a very uh wide fat matrix it's
a k by n matrix where k is
is small so
think of it as independent of n
and what you do is you compute
s times a
and s times b
and you just solve the regression
problem in this much smaller space where
a has been replaced with s times a
and b has been replaced with s times b
and you get some x prime
and the hope is that x prime is a one
plus epsilon approximation
so
depending on which families of matrices
s that you choose
this can be shown to hold
um
right so this is a sort of a black box
reduction you can solve this problem now
exactly say by solving the normal
equations um if k is small so think of k
is
being polynomial and d the small
parameter then this
solving this problem would take p
polynomial in d time
so really the only dependence on n in
the time complexity is just computing
s times a and s times b
okay um
right so how to choose the right
sketching matrix s
so lots of random families of matrices
work
um
so
the most natural that might come to mind
is if s is just a matrix of iid normal
random variables
so if
the parameter k the number of rows of s
is d over epsilon squared you can show
that actually this matrix s has this
property
that if you solve it in the sketch space
you get a 1 plus epsilon approximation
of course
we didn't gain much by doing this
because computing s times a uh might be
you know uh very expensive right s is a
dense matrix of normal random variables
um s times a could take nd squared uh
time or even a little bit larger
and um
okay so
uh
but at least we know there is some s
that works
uh in a very nice paper of uh thomas
sarlos
uh he showed that actually you can
choose s from a much more structured uh
random family of matrices
namely s can be uh
what's called a uh a johnson linen
straws transform or a fast johnson
lindstros transform
and
so what is that so the goal is to try to
choose an s so that you can compute this
product s times a very quickly
and also that you know it has this uh
this property that it works
so
typically um
s
can be factored in the following form it
can be written as p times h
times d
and what are these matrices um
so d is a diagonal matrix
and the entries on the diagonal are plus
or minus one uh with equal probability
and they're chosen independently
okay
h is just the hadamard matrix
there's a fixed matrix
and p all it does is it chooses a random
small subset of rows
of h times d
okay so it's just sampling a small set
of rows
so note that actually uh s can be
applied very quickly
uh to a to a vector right if i want to
apply it to one of the columns of a
you know i can apply a diagonal matrix
in linear time
uh the hadamard transform can be applied
in n log n time to any n dimensional
vector
and i can also easily choose a small
subset of coordinates uh of a vector um
in the most linear time so
so basically s times a can now be
computed um you know if i have d columns
in a
and each column i'm applying s in n log
n time
i can compute this matrix matrix product
in uh n d log n time which uh you know
is much faster than this nd squared time
uh that we solve for uh iud normal
random variables
okay so
um right and why does this work so i
don't have a proof of this on uh in this
talk
um intuitively um
right so what is p doing
p is sampling a small subset of
coordinates right and trying to
estimate the euclidean norm of a vector
um
this doesn't work very well if the if
the if the mass of the of the euclidean
mass of the vector is concentrated on a
few coordinates
right sampling will just miss those
coordinates
so the goal of h is to spread out the
mass uh of these coordinates uh across
all the coordinates right so this is
like the uncertainty principle that uh
you know i can't be both sparse in the
time and frequency domain
of course
you know h is deterministic so i could
apply this to you know
h inverse times a sparse vector
um and then it wouldn't work so there's
some additional randomness with with
this uh matrix d
that that makes it work um
it's just some high level intuition
um
okay yeah so that so then it works for a
fixed vector and then you can get it to
work for the entire
uh subspace spanned by the columns of a
by a net argument but um okay so that's
just some intuition um but let me say
how you can do uh
even faster how you can exploit
the sparsity of your input matrix a
so in a lot of applications your input
although the previous uh time complexity
was n times d log n which is near
optimal in the matrix dimensions
if you have a very sparse matrix a you
might want to you know do it even faster
in time proportional to the number of
non-zero entries of your input matrix
okay so um
so it turns out you can do that and um
we use a uh what's called a count sketch
matrix
which was
a matrix in inspired from the data
stream literature
and uh so let me define what that is so
this random family of matrices
s it's uh
i again have a k by n matrix s
now k is a little bit larger um so
recall in the gaussian case you get a d
over epsilon squared by n matrix now k
is
you know d squared over epsilon squared
still independent of of n
um but the nice thing about s is it's
really sparse
okay so
in fact um s just looks like the
following matrix
so
uh in each column i independently
choose the location uh of a single uh
non-zero element
uh uniformly at random
among uh
the rows
and on that location i put plus or minus
one uh with equal probability
okay so that's that's the whole matrix
actually i mean it's very simple
um
and um
so you can see that s
uh can be you can multiply s and a
matrix a
in time proportional to the number of
non-zero entries of that matrix a
right because for each non-zero entry
you know there's a
i look at the corresponding column and
there's just a single non-zero uh value
in that column
and and surprisingly to me that is this
is that this actually works that uh
that you get this guarantee of a one
plus epsilon approximation if you solve
the problem in the sketch space yeah
uh for this matrix you have to have uh d
squared um
yeah you can increase the sparsity by by
a bit uh
and still get uh
order number of non-zero entries time
and get a smaller value
instead of d squared you can get sort of
d to the one plus
uh arbitrarily small constant
um
and uh
yeah and then there are other trade-offs
too like you can get
a number of non-zero entries of a times
polylog d
with d times polylog uh
uh yeah
and okay so uh
yes we had a bit of a complicated proof
that this actually works and after that
there were uh
some very slick uh simpler and sharper
proofs
um by uh mahoney
uh nelson nguyen
and um and i'm gonna present uh proof of
uh nuen uh just on this slide that this
uh that this matrix s uh
actually works gives this one plus
epsilon approximation
okay so yeah so this slide is a bit
technical but it has the whole proof so
um so let's consider this a join matrix
uh b where we take the columns of a
and we join this vector the column
vector b right
it's an n by d plus one matrix
and let u be an arbitrary
orthonormal basis
for the columns of
b
okay
and i claim that it suffices to show
that for this matrix s this count sketch
matrix that we're choosing at random
that the euclidean norm of s u x um
is one plus or minus epsilon for all
unit vectors x
again this is all we need to show
okay so first you know by linearity if i
show it for all unit x
then it preserves uh the norm of every u
times x uh
up to a relative one plus or minus
epsilon factor
and uh now note that uh
you know if i if i look at ax minus b
for some fixed x
that's just some arbitrary vector in the
column span of of u right
so you know if this holds for all if i
preserve all the norms of vectors in the
column span of u then this means for any
ax minus b
the euclidean norm of s times ax minus b
is one plus or minus epsilon the
euclidean norm of ax minus b
does that make sense
okay so what that means then is now i
can do this sketch and solve uh thing
right because that means that if i
solve for the optimal x in the sketch
space
it has to be a one plus epsilon
approximation
uh to the original problem yeah
so instead of putting the u inside there
you can just say it for all you need x
in this part of the column yeah exactly
yeah
i'm just going to fix you for the rest
of the proof
any other questions
okay um
right so this is what we're going to try
to show
er
okay so
uh you know u has d plus one columns
um
so you know if s has you know dimension
over epsilon squared rows
s times u is a d plus 1 squared over
epsilon squared by d plus 1 matrix
and
what i claim is that it suffices to show
this following
property
this operator norm property
and this will imply this uh
this claim um
that it preserves the norm of all
vectors in the column span
so what does this mean that it preserves
the norm of all vectors in the column
span so it means all the singular values
of s times u are 1 plus or minus epsilon
right in that range
okay well what does that mean
well
if i look at you know u transpose s
transpose s times u
like sort of the square of s times u
all the singular values of that are also
between one plus or minus
theta epsilon right
okay
well
if i subtract the identity from that
then then i'd like all the singular
values there to be theta and most
epsilon
okay
so
it suffices to show that this um this
operator norm is at most epsilon
now i don't know how to do that so
instead i'm going to show the forbinius
norm
is it most epsilon which upper bounds
the operator norm right
okay
so
are you like even in the first operating
room aren't you choice of you stronger
that's just all the like advisor but we
want a minuscule
um
right so
so how are we going to show this
um
okay so forbidden storm is really easy
to work with right you can expand things
you can compute first and second moments
and that's that's how the proof works so
basically
what you can show for this matrix s
this sketching matrix this count sketch
matrix
is that it has the following matrix
product result
if i take any fixed matrices c and d
i can approximate the product c times d
as c times s transpose times s times d
this is like an expectation right this
is in the expected yeah
uh so yeah i didn't say this yeah the
statement yet so um
what uh
er what you can show is that you know
how good of an approximation is c s
transpose s d to c times d
well it depends on the number of rows of
s
okay
i mean um
you know so you can think of s as kind
of like a hashing matrix right
and um
intuitively this increases the number of
hash buckets
so what you can show is that for any
fixed c and d
this uh the difference in forbinius norm
squared
is at most one over the number of rows
of s
times the forbiddenious norm of c
squared times the forbiddenious norm of
d squared in expectation
okay
now i'm not going to give the proof of
this but the proof of this is really
just by expanding this the sides and
computing
uh you know the expectation and uh
i mean that's it right so this matrix s
is very simple
you know i choose a single location
random location in each column and put
plus or minus one there
i i it's not hard to compute this
expectation
given that i'm looking at venus norm so
okay so um and then by a markov bound
you know this is at most a constant
factor larger
uh with constant probability
great just a quick question since i'm
getting confused
what does ss
is there what's the easy description for
the distribution of asset i mean that's
transpose s i mean you'd like it to be
an identity matrix but but it's not uh
because it has a small number of uh
you know s s is a wide fat matrix and s
transpose is uh
is a tall thin matrix
so it's you know it's some
i'm trying to figure out s transpose s
is small or small
oh no it has the right dimension so s
transpose s is this uh the square matrix
which is formed by the product of a tall
thin matrix s transpose and this wide
fat matrix s
so s transpose s is low range
yeah exactly so what you're saying is
that you can have a low rank matrix
approximating the full rank matrix
accurately
yeah accurately meaning that yeah it's
approximating it on this on a low rex
subspace though
i don't know
um
i mean it's approximating it in this
sense what do you mean
i mean you're not approximating like the
operator norm right not approximating
this
uh right i mean it's just sort of
surprising that you know c times d could
be full rank and you're you're going to
give your low rank approximation which
means that you can't do all the singular
values oh yeah definitely it's a
forbidden guarantee so that's just
surprising
um it's the product of the two for
benious norms the frobenius norm is
naturally the dimension of see like
it's operating norms in a intuitive
sense
so
you basically have a d squared factor
from the um c for venus times oh
that'll be the next
step of the proof yeah just just hold it
for a second yeah
it's uh okay so yeah so how do we apply
this uh
this matrix product result
okay
so um
okay so what do we you know we want to
as we said this chain of reasoning we
want to bound this operator norm
so we can plug in c is equal to u
transpose
and d is equal to u
okay
so c times d
is the identity matrix
and
you know
u transpose f transpose s u is exactly
what we want here
so its advice is to you know bound this
right hand side by most epsilon
and uh and that's what you can do by you
you want to choose the number of rows as
small as possible so that this is at
most epsilon
well what is the forbiddenious norm
squared of an uh of the matrix u
uh so it's an orthonormal matrix so it's
just uh d plus one it's it's it's
dimension
yeah
so this is d plus one
it's u transpose this is d plus one this
is uh u
so this thing is order d squared
and so as long as i choose my number of
rows to be order d squared over epsilon
squared
the d squares will cancel and this will
be at most epsilon squared
and i can take square roots yeah
is it a question
should s entries really be plus or minus
one or should they somehow be scaled to
compensate for the number of rows you've
got in that s s is actually plus minus
one so just imagine when you write that
expression in there sort of like the
more
rows or maybe it's columns and s
i might be reversing them so if i is the
the the fact is that s just has a single
non-zero entry per column so you don't
get
like if you had a gaussian matrix you'd
have to scale each entry by
uh
one over the number of rows would be the
new variance
but but here
you just have a single non-zero entry
per
uh per column right so i mean if you
think of just
uh
does that make sense like
if you have k non zeros per column you
scale them by one over root k in general
right
i mean just think about applying s to um
you know standard unit vector
uh
this will just select one of the columns
and that should have unit norm you don't
want to and then
right like so one of the columns just as
a single non-zero entry it's plus or
minus one
if i'm selecting that column i don't
want to scale it okay um
no i mean
something's not clear please yeah
it said i'm sure i need to draw the
picture to see it i think i got the
picture in my notebook but oh of uh
of s or okay
so um
yes so s is very simple so again like s
just has
a single non-zero entry per column
chosen at a random location
and it's one or minus one with equal
probability
you know so if i apply this to ei
i'm just selecting one of these columns
so the columns should have norm one
and since they only have a single
non-zero entry
uh that that value shouldn't be
normalized it should be
it should be one or minus one
so this is very important in the in the
sense that
if you want this time complexity to be
proportional to the number of non-zero
entries of a
one versus a constant is that the
question
no that's not i mean this just affects
the leading uh
so it affects the constant in the
leading order term and it affects the
poly d factor
in the time in the
no
um
yeah nothing immediate
i see
um
okay so i don't know is the gist of this
proof clear like
basically
uh we show this the entire column space
is preserved by showing this single
operator norm bound and
we don't bound the operator norm
directly we instead look at the
frobenius norm and for that we just do a
second moment argument
um
okay um
uh
so if this yeah so i'm just gonna give a
name for this when i preserve the entire
column space
of a matrix b
um
you know so every norm is preserved up
to one plus epsilon i'm going to call
that a subspace embedding okay
so we showed that um
you know with
d squared over epsilon squared rows
s is a subspace embedding for d
dimensional uh
uh space
okay
um
all right so that's actually the main
that that that concludes the part on
these squares regression right so at
this point
you've shown the correctness and you
just solve the problem in the sketch
space
okay
let me
now move on to l1 regression and here
sketching is used in a somewhat
different way
than for least squares regression
okay
uh
okay so for l1 regression you know we
again want to uh
find an x prime for which the l1
distance between ax prime and b is at
most one plus epsilon times the optimal
distance
with high probability
so you know
what would you naturally try to solve
this problem
so natural attempt would be to
draw a random matrix s
um from a k by n uh
uh you know
family of matrices
for a small value of k and try to do
this sketch and solve uh technique right
of computing s times a s times b
and outputting uh the solution in the
sketch space right this would be
a natural extension it turns out that um
this doesn't uh
uh really work um
so
the issue really is we don't have this
random family of matrices um so
er
okay yeah so white is now putting the
solution
x prime in the sketch space uh work
okay so uh we don't know of uh
you know a random family of matrices k
by n random family of matrices with a
small value of k
for which if x prime is the solution in
the sketch space then we get a one plus
epsilon approximation by plugging in x
prime into the original problem
so this is just the issue
one thing we do know though
is that we can find a uh
an s
such that we get this weaker guarantee
that the one norm of ax prime minus b
is at most d log d times the optimal
cost
okay so at least it's uh independent of
n
um
but it's not one plus epsilon
and we will use this this fact to
bootstrap to get a one plus epsilon
approximation
but um you know so most trivially you
can get sort of a root n approximation
just by
uh solving the least squares problem and
relating the two and the one norms so
this is giving something uh interesting
um
yeah so what is s
so s is a matrix of iid cauchy random
variables
okay
and let me i'll see what these are in
the next slide it's just
um
uh you know some continuous random
variables
and they have um
so the property that you get with this s
is that um it's a subspace embedding
uh you know for the column span of this
uh of a together with b
but it has d log d uh distortion
and s has a small number of rows it has
d log d rows
okay so
yeah so what is what are koshi random
variables um
okay so they're not as nice as
uh gaussian random variables um they're
very heavy tailed
here's their density function
you know if you try to compute their
expectation
you get an integral that doesn't
converge
they have infinite variance
um
so yeah they're not very uh it doesn't
seem like they're very useful at all i
guess one question is can we even
generate them
um and that you can so the ratio of two
independent normal random variables
is distributed as a koshy random
variable
yeah so at least you can populate this
matrix s
um
so
you know what is the property that makes
these things useful
so the property is that they're one
stable
so
what does that mean
so it means the following
if a and b are scalars
and c1 and c2 are independent cauchy
random variables
then if i look at a times c 1
plus b times c 2
this is equal in distribution
to the absolute value of a plus the
absolute value of b
times another cauchy c
random variable
okay so they sort of carry l1
information in the same sense if i add
gaussians the variances add so i'm
carrying l2 information
um this is uh the analog for l1
uh so you know if i'm multiplying
a row of cauchys times a a vector i get
something distributed as uh the one norm
of that vector times another cauchy
okay so this is sort of the key property
that is used
what's that
the pdf for this um
so it's
one over one plus x squared
uh times the normalization
it could be like the hand the slope of a
random point on a circle or
um
oh wait that sounds similar to the ratio
of two yeah that sounds
yeah
i think that's what it is
yeah i think i think that's right yeah
um
there's a nice survey by john nolan on p
stable random variables which i think
has that way of looking at cauchy random
variables
does this property characterize cauchy
distributions
yeah yeah it does actually yeah
um
yeah i think that's right yeah
and actually so p stable random
variables exist for any p between zero
and two uh we don't have closed form uh
close form for the density functions for
uh
okay i think we might have a closed form
uh for
p equals 0.5 i'm not sure but for most
of these p we don't have a closed form
uh for the density function
so the c there is a function of a and b
also or not
uh so this is uh so c is uh
so so c by itself is just an independent
cauchy random variable which is a
function of c one and c2 oh right not a
and b
so what is this property saying
if you see the function of c1 and c2
then i don't understand
what this property says
i thought you would want something like
you take three cauchy independent cauchy
c 1 c 2 and c 3 and then near time c 1
plus b times c 2 is equal to a plus b
times e 3
so any distribution that satisfies this
property
is is is one
you're you're asking if this
characterizes a koshy distribution no i
got confused by your comment about
c depending upon c so yeah that's what's
my says you know like somehow if you
take c to like you you take a true
instantiation of a question variable
like c1 c2c and then this this happens
in terms of distributions this happens
in terms of distributions yeah
oh yes i'm sorry yeah
uh
i mean definitely c depends on c1 and c2
it's not a function of c1 and c2 the
fact that if normals you get another
normal
but that the so if you actually if you
add a normal distribution with um
varying or with standard deviation a to
one standard deviation b
you get one with standard deviation
square root a squared plus b squared
okay right so here instead of getting
square root a squared plus because
normal is the vector it adds l1 l2 right
but c is independent yeah well
like they just think about this
difference
what they just say
this is this is equality and
distribution is that is that was not
clear
yeah okay like we talked about yeah no i
mean uh
sure sure yeah okay
when you prove it oh okay fine
um
okay so
let me say how you use uh sketching to
solve a one regression
um
so uh
okay so basically
um
right so again we're going to create
this adjoint matrix a uh and b
and now we're going to do something
differently so we're going to compute s
times b where s is this matrix of iod
cauchys
and what we're going to do is we're
going to compute a qr factorization of
this
okay
so
in the standard l2 sense right so
q has orthonormal columns r is a change
of basis matrix q times r
is s times b
and um the point here is that b times r
inverse
is going to be a well conditioning of b
in a certain sense
um
so uh
note that uh s times b times r inverse
has orthonormal columns it's just equal
to q
but now i'm saying use this uh
change of basis matrix r found in the
sketch space
in the original space and see what
happens
right does br inverse have certain nice
properties
okay so it has the following uh
uh
two properties
which might look a little bit weird
but i'll explain uh what they mean so
the first property is that
if i look at b times our inverse
and i look at the entry wise l1 norm of
this matrix
it's not too large
okay um now first of all but by itself
that's a useless statement right because
uh i can always scale all the entries of
b down arbitrarily small but there will
be a another condition
okay so let me first uh
say er
why
br inverse has small entry wise a one
norm
okay so one way of computing that is
just to take the sum uh over all the
columns
of the one norm of br inverse of that
column br inverse times ei
which we know since s is a
subspace embedding
is at most uh the sum over all the
columns of the one norm of s times br
inverse ei
okay now s
is a small is a small matrix it only has
d log d rows
so i can relate the one norm to the two
norm
and so this is the most
uh
the number of rows of s
d log d to the point five times the sum
of the two norms of the columns
okay
but right sbr inverse
is just q
this this is
has orthonormal columns
so
this is just equal to one
so when i sum over d terms i get
some d d times root d roughly so so i uh
i get a uh
poly d
as the sum of the the l one uh entry
wise l1 of this uh matrix
okay and as i said that's not useful by
itself
but you also have this additional
property
and let me
explain it so
for any vector x its infinity norm is is
less than or equal to its two norm
sbr inverse has orthonormal columns
so i can just
write this as sbr inverse
x to norm
the two norm is less than the one norm
and now i use that s is a subspace
embedding so
the one norm of sbr inverse x is the
most d log d times the one number of br
inverse x
okay so there are two properties here
the first property is that the
entry-wise l1 norm is is is not too
large
and the other property is if i apply br
inverse to any vector x
um i can't shrink
the one norm of x too much
right because
you know the infinity norm is at most uh
d log d times
uh this one norm
if i just scaled all the entries to be
very small then this property would not
hold
um
yeah of course yeah so the last
inequality is this something that holds
with high probability for the hershey s
oh yeah so um with
say with constant probability s is a
subspace embedding it preserves all the
vectors
uh one norm up to a d log d factor so
this is a probabilistic statement but
but first one also
uh
it is this is also a probabilistic
statement yeah so condition on the fact
that s is a subspace embedding
preserving all vectors up to a d log d
vector and now perform this analysis
um
so
okay so you know um
okay so so these are two properties that
you get out of this and the nice thing
about them is that uh
they make
yeah uh go ahead is there a way to test
whether s is a subspace embedding and if
not too simple again
um
for uh uh okay so for
for this application is the subspace
embedding um
if
oh just
there should be some simple way to test
this uh
no
because i think for the problem of
graphs
asking whether two graphs approximate
each other in this sense is very similar
to sparse's cut
i thought about this a little bit
um
yeah but but we don't care about you
know uh
approximation right so sparse's cut is
easy if i allow
an approximate an approximation factor
oh if you if you only want to test are
they subspacing betting up to
if you're willing to say test with is it
either not an embedding at all or one up
to like a d squared factor or something
maybe
this is a good question i don't yeah so
um
because you would need to do something
like this in order to turn this into a
reliable algorithm to boost the
probability of success right
well so like for the downstream
application of regression
you could just run this independently
some number of times and then you get a
regression vector and you just compute
the cost of all these and take the best
one
um oh so i didn't say why
so what is what does this even mean uh
so what the way we're going to try to
solve l1 regression is we're going to
try to sample a small number of rows
of of uh of a and corresponding
coordinate and b
reweight them
and and to solve the regression problem
on that sample
and use that as a solution for the
original problem
um and the sampling has to be done
uh
in a certain way so um
so it's going to be done so let me just
describe on the next slide
um how do we do
sampling okay so this is just important
sampling uh 101
we want to
estimate the sum of y i's
for non-negative uh
uh y i's
and uh suppose we sample y i with
probability p i
um and we consider the following uh
estimator t
which is the sum from i equals one to n
of an indicator which says if y i was
sampled
times y i over p i
okay
so then for any
uh
any set of pi's that i choose you know
the expectation of this random variable
uh
you know i get the sum of p i times y i
over p i i get what i want an
expectation
um
the variance
of t is upper bounded by the second
moment and uh
so uh you know the expectation of this
thing squared is still p i
so i get p i times y i squared over p i
squared
i can pull out sort of the maximum
entry here so i get a max
i y i p i
times what i want uh
to estimate just by canceling one of the
pis
so what you really want to show an
important sampling uh is that this
maximum uh
is small
so you have small variance
um
you know we would like that this maximum
to be bounded by
epsilon squared times the uh
the quantity we're trying to estimate
so then we'll get a
you know a one plus epsilon
approximation
this is a standard important sampling
framework and um for us what we apply
this uh
framework to
is uh
y y i is going to be
the
i coordinate
the absolute value of the i coordinate
of ax minus b
for a fixed x
okay so
if i if i take this y i
and i plug it into here this is just the
one norm of ax minus b right
and i'm trying to use sampling to
approximate the one norm of ax minus b
for a fixed x
and i can't just uniformly sample the
coordinates right so i instead do this
important sampling
and it turns out that if you set the
probabilities these p i's
to be proportional
to the one norms
of uh the rows of this wall condition
matrix br inverse
times uh polyd uh over epsilon factor
then this important sampling actually
works that is that for a fixed vector um
so um you know what is the expected
number of samples also that i have it's
this it's the sum of the pi's
and we said that the
the overall l one norm
entry wise uh l1 norm of inverse is is
poly d is something small
so the overall expected number of
samples is going to be poly d
this is an important uh point
and you can show that uh
you know you can bound this this maximum
for important sampling if you use these
probabilities which i won't
say why but you can use the well
condition those two properties that i
said about being well conditioned to
argue that this maximum is not too large
so that's for a fixed x we preserve it's
one norm uh
now yeah can you say why uh what's the
intuition of those pi should add up to
one since their probabilities
uh
no so these pis uh they don't add up to
one so uh
so yeah so for each for each um
for each coordinate i decide to include
it with probability pi the pis actually
add up to poly d
uh and that's the pi is also yeah okay
um
yeah so this this shows that you know if
i do the sampling according to the
to the road norms of this well condition
basis
important sampling works and i preserve
the one norm of any fixed ax minus b
in my subspace
okay with a slightly stronger argument
with the using bernstein's inequality
uh you can show that you preserve the
one norm with high probability
okay and now you put a net
on the d-dimensional
space which is
say the intersection of the subspace and
the unit at one ball
and you have exponential and d vectors
but it's fine since you have very high
concentration you can union bound over
all of them
this is the intuition
um
so that's the whole algorithm you you
sample poly d over epsilon rows uh
according to these one norms
and um
you uh you solve the problem in this uh
sketch space
and um you know so formally what does
this mean
what does important sampling mean well i
have this matrix t which is diagonal
where i have a zero on the diagonal if
the row is not sampled
and i have one over the probability the
row is sampled
if i do sample it right so this is just
implementing important sampling as a
matrix product
and what you can show is that
via this uh this argument that we just
discussed that you get this one plus
epsilon
subspace embedding property
so now so now you can uh
to solve it in the sketch space
using say linear programming
um
okay and uh
yeah so
um
so these are yeah okay so
uh let me just say that this is the most
expensive operation in this is computing
s times a
um
the other operations are done in the
sketch space finding this
this this preconditioning
there is something here where you need
to
find the one norms of this matrix to
sample
but you don't have to explicitly compute
b times r inverse you can just
suffice is just to have approximations
to all the
the row norms
this can be done quickly
so really if you look at it the main uh
bottleneck is computing s times a
uh where s is this dense matrix of id
koshi random variables
and um
you know you can speed this up
in various ways uh inspired by the ways
for speeding up l2 regression
so one way is to choose a diagonal
matrix
of cauchys
and this count sketch matrix we talked
about for l2
so uh mangan mahoney shows that show
that this uh also provides a uh subspace
embedding instead of being d log d
distortion it's some poly d distortion
but the whole argument is
uh goes through
uh in a similar way
you can uh reduce the number of samples
uh in the in the second stage in this
important sampling stage
if instead of choosing koshi random
variables
you choose uh
this so it's a product of the count
sketch matrix and a diagonal matrix
where now instead of these being cauchys
they're reciprocals of exponential
random variables
and this uses a nice stability property
about exponential random variables
that was
inspired for us by work of andoni
which is that if i take scalar's y i and
independent exponentials e i then the
maximum
of y i over e i
is uh equal in distribution to the one
norm of y uh over uh over an exponential
so it's it's max stable in this sense
why is this useful
you can sort of interpret this matrix as
a hashing matrix and so when i multiply
by a vector x
the maximum entry is going to be
proportional to the one norm over an
exponential
and this hatching matrix
will will sort of preserve the maximum
value the max the maximum in the hash
bucket will be the maximum value
and so you get an embedding into l
infinity actually
but since it's low dimensional
it's an embedding into l1 as well
um
okay so this is and uh actually so yeah
so for recent work on sampling based
algorithms with uh with fewer samples
see uh richard's talk uh later today
um
yeah
and um
okay so
uh let me just
uh
yeah i guess i don't have time to cover
low rank approximation so
let me just mention some some results on
uh
concerning regression so
um
what we saw for regression
uh is you know least absolute deviation
regression and least squares regression
but there's a whole you know you can
imagine an arbitrary cost function on
the
uh on the coordinates um
so you can suppose you define the
function m from the reals to the
non-negative reals
then you can just look at the cost
function of a vector
as being m applied to each uh
coordinate and summing these up
so these are called m estimators
and
so yeah least squares in l1 regression
are special cases
um
and uh
another interesting case that's studied
in practice is called the huber uh
penalty function where
uh huber is
a mixture of l2 squared and l1 so
near the origin this function looks like
l2 squared
but as i move away from the origin
it looks like l1
and there's a parameter you can choose
so that you know when you flip from l2
to l1
um
and uh this uh one nice thing about the
huber function is that uh you know it
enjoys the smoothness properties of l2
so close to the origin you know i have
the smoothness property
and it also enjoys the robustness
properties of l1
so it behaves like l1
for outliers
and
in recent work with ken
we show that for
you know a class of m estimators which
have at least linear
and most quadratic growth you can get a
constant factor approximation in roughly
number of non-zero entries of your input
matrix uh time
um
okay so
yeah i didn't get a chance to cover a
low rank approximation um so i have a
recent monograph on a lot of this stuff
which includes
uh what i discussed and other problems
uh
concerning low rank approximation
that i didn't get into
and uh so
um
yeah so let me just uh conclude uh
that's all
yeah is there a way to do l2 uh to do
sketching for l2 regression in a way
that also guarantees that the residual
is close to orthogonal to the column
space of a because otherwise you don't
get any guarantee on x you get a
guarantee on the residual but not on the
model yeah so basically if your matrix a
is reasonably well conditioned you can
get a you can get a bound which depends
on the on
on the condition number of that matrix
so basically how close x is to the
optimal x star
is that your question like yes yeah it
also depends i don't think i think that
also depends on how far b
is from the column space of a not just
on the e oh yeah yeah yeah you'll have a
multiplicative norm of of b as well i
think so this is in sarlos's paper
actually uh
yeah so you can get
um
see so
i think it might be dependence of like
one over the
condition number
i mean so you can bound the difference
in euclidean norm euclidean distance
between x and x prime
as um
yes
i'm not entirely i don't remember the
bound exactly but it's in solo's paper
actually so um
yeah sorry
yeah
a little bit longer well balancing the
size of these sketches so in the l2 case
it's d squared over epsilon squared
necessary yeah for if you want only one
yeah so it it this is this trade-off
that i mentioned that uh if you have a
single non-zero entry per column you
need at least d squared rows
um but you can if you have uh polylog d
entries per column
you can get d polylog d uh rose this is
a result of uh nelson and nguyen and
they also wrote a paper on lower bounds
that includes the lower bounds on all
these cases as well
yeah so there are also lower bounds
so actually like for this matrix it's
not hard to see if you apply it to the
identity matrix
i could
you need at least d squared uh rows
because you'll have a collision with
constant probability of two of the
columns and they'll cancel and the rank
will be reduced from d to something
smaller so the hard instance is actually
identity matrix for for that sketching
matrix there's also an interesting
feature which is that unless you have at
least one over epsilon non zeros per
column you can't squeeze below d squared
at all
you need to you can need to jump you
basically don't get any benefit until
you jump from one to about one over
epsilon non-zero as performance
but then you can go down to arbitrary
powers of d between one and two
thank you very much